[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue faible en verre
société artisanale implanté au vésinet
bleu blanc vert fabrique des produits
d'entretien ménagers écologiques ont
zéro déchet véronique et constance mais
répit se sont lancées suite à des
problèmes de santé vous savez déjà
longtemps qu'on faisait des produits
dans des produits d'entretien avec ma
mère parce que moi j'ai des problèmes
d'eczéma et ma mère a des problèmes de
thyroïde et on voulait du coup faire
découvrir ces produits là notre
entourage donc à la fin du premier
confinement on s'est dit qu'on allait se
lancer bleu blanc vert propose huit
produits ils sont réalisés avec peu
d'ingrédients une composition
transparente comme cette lessive
fabriqués à partir d'eau de savon de
marseille de bicarbonate de soude et de
cristaux sud alors là on est en train de
préparer la lessive envoyer l'eau elle
chauffe et on va mettre dedans
le savant marseille naturelles ou encore
segal et là ce sont des galets
détartrant pour les toilettes
toujours avec quatre ingrédients
uniquement tout est naturel jusqu'à la
colle fabriqués maison l'entreprise a
recours à l'économie circulaire
l'emballage est consigné ou réalisés à
partir de récupération
ici rien n'est laissé au hasard jusqu
aux graphismes on a que du noir pour
éviter des couleurs al impression qu
est-ce que c'est très polluant les
couleurs a l'impression que je voulais
faire attention à ce que pour une source
noir pour trouver en mono couleurs et du
coup le graphe de kiabi mais le craft si
ce n'est pas une impression du bon
le zéro déchet un mode de vie qui tient
à coeur à véronique elle livre ses
astuces sur le compte instagram de bleu
blanc vert pour sensibiliser
je lutte contre les micro plastiques
avec ma lessive je n'utilise pas de
plastique et en fait je fais aussi
attention non seulement à la planète
qu'on va laisser à nos enfants mais
aussi à l'intérêt individuel et aux gens
chaque chaque personne puisque nos
produits sont aussi sans matières
toxiques donc bonne pour la santé et
c'est aussi très important pour moi
dernier produit en date pour la marque
le stick détachant
[Musique]